في احد مقالاتكم عوده الى موضوع اتفاقيات
السلام مع اسرائيل في احد مقالاتكم قلت
بانه غير صحيح ان الاتفاقيات المبرمه بين
اسرائيل ودون ملتقى ليست
وهي ليست مثل ما تصف البيانات الرسميه
اتفاقيات سلام ماذا تقصد بذلك
اسرائيل ليست في حاله حرب مع الامارات
العربيه المتحده او المغرب او البحرين او
السودان كل واحد من هذه الدول العربيه سبق
او ان جرى من دون العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
الكامله ايضا وهذا يشمل العديد من
الاتصالات بين المسؤولين في حكومه تلك
الدول
ولكن يعني ما الذي يهم اسرائيل في هذه
الحاله ما الذي تركز عليه في مساله سعيها
لاقامت علاقات
مع دول عربيه هل هي علاقات مع دول متكافئه
ام الترويج لفكره تشكيل تحالف مناهض
لايران بدرجه الاولى